bonjour à tous je suis soué le techtech
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de ce qui
va changer lors des élections de mars
2015 et qu'est-ce qui va changer lors
des élections de mars 2015 au niveau du
département des changements très
importants et multiples auront lieu lors
des élections de ce mois de mars 2015
d'abord le Conseil général va changer de
nom il s'appellera dorenavant le conseil
départemental de même les élections pour
élire les élus du conseil départemental
ne seront plus des élections cantonales
mais des élections départementales mais
ce ne sont pas là les principaux
changements et quels sont les principaux
changements les principaux changement
sont au nombre de TR primo moins de
canton qu'auparavant secondo une
parfaite parité hommes-femm des élus
tertio les élus sont choisis dans leur
totalité pour 6 ans combien de cantons y
aura-t-il maintenant à la Réunion
jusqu'à maintenant la réunion était
découpée en 49 cantons très inégaux en
terme d'équilibre et de représentativité
de la population un décret en Conseil
d'État paru le 24 février 2014 cré 25
nouveaux cantons en remplacement des 49
anciens chaque canton aura donc en
moyenne plus ou moins 30000 habitants et
chaque canton aura un élu féminin et un
élu masculin pourquoi et comment il y
aura-t-il une élu féminine et un élu
masculin dans chaque canton c'est le
second grand changement les candidats
aux élections départementales doivent se
présenter en un binôme constitué
obligatoirement d'une femme et d'un
homme leurs deux suppléentss sont
également un homme et une femme les deux
membres du binôme élus au bout du prer
ou du second tour et qui sont
obligatoirement une femme et un homme
exerceront alors leur mandat de
conseiller départemental indépendamment
l'un de l'autre il y aura donc ainsi une
femme et un homme élu par canton et le
Conseil départemental sera ainsi composé
de 25 femmes et de 25 hommes alors que
dans l'assemblée actuelle du conseil
général il y a 38 hommes et seulement 11
femmes le nouveau conseil départemental
aura donc une parité parfaite et pour la
durée totale de leur mandat de 6 ans et
le troisème changement important avant
la moitié des élus était changé tous les
3 ans à partir de cette année l'ensemble
des conseillers départementaux sera élu
pour l'ensemble de la mandature de 6 ans
quand auront lieu les prochaines
élections départementales les prochaines
élections auront lieu pour le premier
tour le Dimanche 22 mars et dans le cas
d'un éventuel second tour le dimanche 29
mars 2015 et concrètement quel rôle ont
les conseillers départementaux à la
Réunion les conseillers départementaux
votent des actions destinées aux
habitants de La Réunion et qui impactent
le quotidien des réunionnis par exemple
l'action sociale la protection de la
jeunesse les collèges les aménagements
routiers l'organisation des transports
interurbains ainsi que des personnes
âgées et des personnes porteuses de
handicap les élus participent aussi aux
décisions prises par les partenaires du
département il veillent ainsi à la bonne
application du projet départ
l'objectif est d'améliorer la vie
quotidienne des habitants de notre île
il est donc très important d'aller voter
aux élections départemental car elles
sont importantes pour le devenir de
notre île et le bien-être de ses
habitants j'espère que vous avez bien
compris l'Ance de ces élections
départementales à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode